Batman on Batman what what else what's
next on the list of news let's see it
was a bunch of Marvel [ __ ] not that
Captain Marvel
that was huge man number one they showed
images of brie Larson in the costume
number two they showed the d23 footage
of infinity wars what are they calling
it yeah Avengers infinity war
this one's infinity war and the next one
is untitled Devin - okay so infinity war
footage that was shown at d23 but
apparently had one added piece that
wasn't at d23 because nobody was talking
about it on twitter they in that footage
the Avengers footage Captain Marvel is
there and that's nothing that I've heard
about was going to happen like which
they gave out another piece of
information which then makes you go what
the [ __ ] is going on when they do the
Captain Marvel movie it is set in the
90s and we're going to see Sam Jackson
as Nick Fury with two good eyes that's
what they announce today and you're like
wait how is this possible and then the
character is also going to be in
infinity woman this is everything we
learned today out of the panel and stuff
how do you think they're accomplishing
that got a [ __ ] with time somehow
right there's one of the gems a time Jim
or something like that yes the Infinity
gem is another all infinite don't wait
one of them's a time Jim maybe that's
the way to do I think that's [ __ ]
awesome number one 90s costume that's
fantastic because everybody wants 90s
costume yes and yet just Sam Jackson not
having to stumble awkwardly to the left
yes
what do you think they're gonna do I
mean because we've seen Sam Jackson like
fiddle the last few Avengers films and
the only the only age in one direction
so this is a movie that's set in the 90s
is there any chance that it's not Sam
Jackson no like say always it's always
Sam and Martha vetting a [ __ ] ton Jodi
age and they have they have now
pioneered the art of making old men look
half way young it's true yeah but
usually for like 30 seconds in the movie
if he's a main character man that's a
long time that's a lot of shot I like
the back of a bald head oh good point
[ __ ] yeah better [ __ ] filmmaker than
I am man like I was sitting there going
we got to spend a lot of money or like
no don't shoot over here could use you
years ago I'm exciting news that they're
putting Captain Marvel in the movie but
obviously look they've always been
talking about hey man Captain Marvel is
coming hey man Captain Marvel's comes
but after the year of Wonder Woman like
hey man cap Marvel's here for real we go
here she is look at her isn't awesome so
there Marvel finally thrown in with the
ladies in for any male lead Michelle
Pfeiffer is cast as Janet Van Dyne in
ant-man are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me they
doubt that yeah that's pretty damn
awesome man and there's a scene that
they played in the panel which I would
give my eyeteeth to see of Paul Rudd and
Michael Pena explaining the history of
the MCU to Janet Van Dyne that's in the
that's bad that the footage that they
showed from from a man and a wash I am
here about this remember the time when
like you know David fought the [ __ ]
giant guy and the airport that was cool
right member that on the time will type
out a guy food fun Queens member a guy
that's what they were doing a whole
scene of the whole scene of that how
long was it mmm two minutes is it meant
to be a trailer is it sounding so I
guess from the flick so are they're
shooting on ant-man in the waspretty
yeah
are they done or they're like revving
little production wow man I had no idea
I didn't know that they were shown that
I thought like they've come to comic-con
and show the Avengers footage and
everybody like thank you
coming without touching themselves and
should but they they [ __ ] came overly
prepared overly packed once again it's
an example of [ __ ] like DC comes in
the like la guitar Justice League Weiner
you know and everyone's like a little
house [ __ ] impressive than Marvel's
like look at this [ __ ] monster open
the doors in the back here at table man
they [ __ ] brought like just an army
to a knife fight
so that's blank black panther footage
yet avengers for avengers footage teensy
clip mmm and so a new tour trailer and
the new thor trailer which is fantastic
and it teensy clips from ant-man so
that's for big things and this is the
end right like Avengers infinity war it
represents the end of phase 3 right and
so that de metal takes off phase 4 are
you [ __ ] me yeah so then after that
the next Avengers movie is phase 4 as
well
they keep talents like don't expect
anything to be the same things and you
said that you think they're gonna kill
Captain America yeah that's your belief
that's my belief is it your hope I mean
as a storyteller Sturgill yeah like that
would be satisfying that is that if
Coulson's death is the thing that
initiates the Avengers with Captain
America's beating heart then his death
would be the perfect way to transition
into a completely different phase that's
where I go cuz I'm a heartless bastard
good writing man that's [ __ ] I really
want to watch your Avengers movies well
next time you hugged a dude just drop a
brother's name yeah man
[Applause]
[Laughter]
particularly your load while you do it
just they get it off me man he's [ __ ]
whispered something in my ear what he's
I said mark barnard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]